[Music]
in depth new news submitted by jesus
take the wheel
Oh homie a YouTube family is selling a
doll version of their newborn son whoa
genius yeah amazing I would do it
they monetized it monetize it again okay
is it cute you can sip yourself but
first let me show you is it creep creep
really lifelike I will show you so this
is a family from the UK named the Ingham
family in him family and guy and they
have 1.2 million subscribers on YouTube
and so they're like family vloggers and
their newest addition was born in March
and so this little baby is the baby that
they decided to make a doll around like
a plush doll no like one of those
realistic solvers yeah Oh like the ones
that [ __ ] open up their eyes and cold
their eyes and open up their eyes I
don't know if it's scary though where's
born no so they have the last born I
think we have four kids Jace is the
youngest then there's Isla who seven as
May who's nine and Isabelle was 13 and
this is all names there are pretty cool
names but when they were all born they
didn't have access to a white label doll
factory yeah that's kind of [ __ ] up
like this one gets one but what about
the other four didn't have the access
back then they were just coming off
maybe the parents thought the other four
way too ugly and then the new one is the
best look like at all already that's the
baby oh so this is the baby
oh sure thought that was a doll this is
the baby as well wow the baby looks like
a doll the baby should be a doll yeah
that baby has every right to be oh he
looks perfect like I love that's crazy
so this baby's be that's a really good
looking baby it is
everyone take a shot every time we say
the word [ __ ] baby baby baby baby
baby doll
that's a sleepy baby this doll oh that
looks less cool and they're selling it
for $300 or something
that's the doll they made out of actual
baby look at that hair though that's
almost like four hundred four hundred
fifty dollars yes they're saying why do
babies look like a burrito with limbs so
it translates from three hundred and
forty dollars to three four hundred
eighteen dollars that's the us damn
dollar conversion is because you if you
buy the one with like Dookie in the
diaper no so it's the one that comes
with three outfits I had a dummy clip
nappies birth certificate gift bag in a
pen
the limited edition baby that's that's
the higher price one is that the actual
doll or the the junior doll this is Jay
does the pen have the baby's head on top
why does the doll look like the real
baby and then the real baby look like a
doll right and the doll has a shadow I
know right that's weird
it's red its yard it's been crying all
night what's so creepy that was like the
birth certificate so like this kid is
like everyone's gonna know who the [ __ ]
this kid is for like the rest of his
[ __ ] life yeah it can't like get away
with a fake ID it can't like do anything
that I did maybe we'll never get to
marry a rich man baby yes this is a real
baby that baby looks perfect that's like
a cute I like how many people are drunk
right now yeah true well don't wait till
hospital money I like that baby's outfit
future this is your future what would
you name your baby my baby I already
have a name action you made it up no no
I keep okay me and Nikki already decided
run and be crazy I don't know what it is
to market oh I don't want anyone in our
friend group just do it no it doesn't
matter for the player girl we got that
figured out crab a don't one post mated
maybe name this is no yeah no I'm an
actual baby post made it to you yeah you
don't have to pop out the baby yeah we
great how do you guys feel about this
you guys think is weird that they're
like cell
the apps it's weird lifelike dolls are
just weird puget yeah creepy so one
thing to mention though is that they're
saying that they did not use the baby at
all to like mold the silicone the doll
is just that the doll like this company
that came out with the doll or who's
making the doll they just slap Jason's
name on it and the fact that there's my
label baby I told you why would they
want why would people want for $400 why
do people are they gonna pretend are
they like they want to pretend that
they're moms what is this for yeah so
this is a baby
based on Jase at two weeks old and it's
limited edition two hundred and fifty
dollars will be produced and they're
saying that alone what's genius about
this you can sell the two week baby the
four week baby the eight week baby the
six month baby and you have the whole
set and what I think is nice about this
is I read a little bit about this the
family they actually not so like it's we
love how we didn't have to use Jase to
make the doll we use like a another baby
don't worry guys we didn't use James we
found some mother kind of or family and
we use the values there baby we used one
of these orphans that no one cares about
put a little straw in his mouth and then
we did the cast around them could you
imagine it looks identical do you guys
think this is where then so like that's
you're making an imitation of a baby
right but what about when they made the
exact replica of a porn stars [ __ ] yeah
so that's the thing people are saying
that this is [ __ ] creepy because you
don't know who's gonna buy this like oh
you think people are gonna buy to [ __ ]
it
maybe oh yeah I'm creepy bug oh yeah
it's part of the same factory silicone
white label factors making all this [ __ ]
you're not wrong though that's true what
are the masses you could [ __ ] anything
what are you talking about so [ __ ]
I'm just talking about replicas of
things when is it weird when the replica
is made it's weird to buy a porn stars
[ __ ] - oh that's weird - right
I kind of want one though I kind of want
to do in a mine and then like if I die
in you and bike I want to be like I'm
bombed or whatever and then like have my
funeral and like have my makeup artist
do my makeup take tons of selfies with
people be late to the funeral then if
they can just like cut my [ __ ] off
dip it in gold and then
put like a verified checkmark on it and
then put it on a shelf so it'd be like a
dead [ __ ] on a shelf oh wow people
can't [ __ ] it if it's not that verified
it's a verified gold doing when you were
saying that if immediately made me think
of that bodies exhibit that we saw we
saw a lot of old [ __ ] I actually saw a
shoe that we saw a human vagina like the
inside cuz like everything was gone and
it was all shriveled or some tight [ __ ]
there did it look like hamburger me know
if it was the inside you see well you
see the lips to your lips one just hair
on it - I could do this because I'm
touching it and you know what it was
like prosciutto like everything was like
dried ham and [ __ ] like all over like I
was like oh man I do not recommend god I
feel like I'm in a freezer like with the
hanging meats you know I was like I
can't believe people pay to cover this
thing Wow thank you guys I thought it
was from laughs I liked it I liked it -
sorry I'll go again the fake thing like
I hated knowing that it was a real-life
person like it was someone this belonged
to someone that was alive and they were
probably yeah a Chinese dissident cool
though when I close my eyes and think
about my body I see all those parts that
are lighting up inside does it make you
hungry no not like mom not my own other
people's things make you hungry okay
yeah you know what I think I'm
accountable cuz laughs okay so first is
I I was I was we were filming and I saw
anatomy book and we were doing a scene
and then I was hungry and I looked at
the meat fibers and I was like this is
like a steak and then after that we saw
the bodies exhibit and I started
thinking about like prosciutto and all
the salami and like hanging meats and
then I was like who brought the anatomy
book to Vegas no no he we have a
separate day several years ago okay
interesting
I don't want to do it I just I just see
that I just see that the similarities
you know like protein does look similar
Oh gene is that from same dude oh my
gosh I mean it's still weird like it's
the I don't want to do it I'm just
seeing the similarity and I'm like damn
dude like how is it the same
like this looks like that [ __ ] ham
that was hanging and like I would eat it
look what's weirded you guys the porn
star [ __ ] or the porn star like lips
worth I hold it to their mouth I've
never seen that I've seen that in the
[ __ ] yeah yeah fleshlight you could
buy like your favorite porn stars has
Wow or [ __ ] I was thinking that you're
talking about them living everyday with
those rules
yeah meets you at our making oh it was a
bit no no not a bit you can actually buy
the their lips and you can [ __ ] it if
you want it's the house that you could
buy the triple set if you want more if
you're a gentleman you can also make out
with it or you could come inside
I think kiss are after and then you come
you're a gentleman and then you can
whisper her that it's okay after yeah
how much I love you like you move the
hair from her ear first right and then
you put her in the dishwasher that's one
of the funniest things I've heard all
day that's so [ __ ] fun alright gos
question cuz she was asking me what's
the response from the masses and so a
lot of people are saying that this is
[ __ ] creepy why would you do this
like monetizing this way is just really
[ __ ] creepy especially off of your
newborn kid and but there were other
people who are hardcore fans and they
were saying like yeah I can't wait to
have my own Jace and I could cuddle with
them and play with them and so they're
also saying that once you have this Jace
reborn doll that they will have these
tea parties tea parties and that's when
you will be able to meet the family
and hang out like a meet-and-greet thing
because you bought why would you want to
meet these [ __ ] because you bought
the baby
you bought the baby you want to meet
them well I don't want to meet the
people that bought the baby baby no
you're gonna attract the weirdest
[ __ ] then don't make the baby
you should have made a [ __ ] book
about your family and meet them that's
better the people that buy your books
they're not the ones that are trying to
[ __ ] your kids we don't know they'll try
to [ __ ] them well I thought that's what
we were saying some of these guys are
gonna try to [ __ ] their kids that's what
some people are saying you don't know
who's gonna be buying these dogs that's
what I'm saying is do you want that to
leak into your family okay if they were
all like old grandmas that would like
that's kind of cute for their 14 year
olds and they're like whatever they're
kind of like I don't want my 14 year old
girl playing with the baby because this
she's an auto real baby I was like [ __ ]
you better I'll get pregnant gonna steal
your baby
oh listen these people are probably
already [ __ ] Cabbage Patch dolls and
stuff like that
they're not gonna buy a foreign dollar
thing to [ __ ] it that's true they're too
cheap that's true that's best yeah